we all have this inherent fear of been
in the water I think we should put in a
pool cover even though in your mind you
understand that the pool is only a few
feet
deep Marco follow when the lights go
out anything could be beneath
[Music]
you this is a story about a d who
seeking a better life moves in this
house with a backyard
[Music]
pool wanting fun and time
together maybe we should have the
cookout or something that's a great
idea and what they get is
a terrifying secret that is hidden
beneath the surface of that
water what do you want me why don't you
run for me what are
you
[Music]
do it's important for me to find the
next generation of filmmakers who have
what it takes but may not have the
platform to be seen I was substitute
teaching elementary school and I was
writing night swim is about how I felt
when I was a kid in a pool by myself
convinced that there was something
beneath
me you saw something didn't
you James Juan and Jason Blum made some
of the most iconic horror films of the
last decade and a half you Team Up When
It's a roller coaster
ride with Bryce we were completely won
over by his passion and vision for the
movie I want people to be holding their
breath in the theater it's like edge of
your seat biting your
Nails there's something beneath the
water